à bord de la sterne bertron adore
remonter la loire à la voile au plat et
le temps ici on est dans un lieu
mythique de la marine de loi il y a très
longtemps la loire ici c'était une
autoroute
des milliers de bateaux descendait
depuis saint rambert au dessus de roanne
pour aller jusqu'à orléans
de l'autre côté donc on a des bateaux
qui vont remonter la loire en utilisant
le vent d'ouest qui soudent de l'océan
pour arriver là aussi orléans et de là à
aller à paris
allez on y va les femmes et les enfants
d'abord
depuis les beaux jours le marinier amar
et c'est tout à châtillon sur loire pour
partager sa passion du fleuve avec les
visiteurs
hélas ici on est exactement à l'arrivée
avec les cluses de menthe l'eau du canal
latéral à la loire et pour traverser la
loire
on va aménager tout un espace ici avec
des digues pour aller rejoindre les
cluses des combles qui est juste en face
qui va nous permettre de rejoindre le
canal de briare il conduit ainsi les
touristes à travers l'histoire du
transport fluvial du 17e au 19e siècle
et surtout ce carrefour dangereux il
fallait quelquefois six jours pour aller
d'une écluse à l'autre un passage obligé
pour tous ceux qui venaient du sud
toutes les marchandises qui venait du
massif central le bois le charbon et
cetera pour aller livrer paris et tout
ce qui venait de la route des indes la
route de la soie qui arrivait au port de
marseille on avait un trafic colossal et
pour éviter les nombreux échouage au
milieu du fleuve en 1840 l'homme a
construit le pont de châtillon et
surtout un escargot en pierre unique en
son genre pour permettre aux chevaux de
halage de descendre la digue pour tirer
les péniches c'est toujours intéressant
de connaître l'histoire et le contexte
orchidées chiffres nous c'est un grand
bénéfice ces cinq journées c'est
enrichissant la navigation réserve
toujours de belles surprises
le décollage d'un héron cendré sur un
banc de sable et des oiseaux il ya des
oiseaux partout c
c'est la nature nous on est à paris il y
aussi des gourmandises
c'est le domaine de nathalie les pousses
du marinier je vous ai préparé une tarte
à la fleur de reine des prés mais aussi
de la crème à la pimprenelle et à
l'origan sauvage une tisane de tanaisie
les bords de loire se déguste aussi oui
moi je suis passionné des plantes
sauvages comestibles et en bord de loire
est haut en bord de canots il ya tout ce
qu'il faut il ya énormément de plantes
une grande diversité beaucoup de plans
qui se mange
de retour à lécluse de menthe l'eau le
message de bertrand devient plus
militants maintenant on en est là la
loire des chaussées tout s'écroule ça
sans sable et sept écluses qui ne
fonctionnent plus ne permet plus de
chasser le sahb régulièrement
bilan des courses on est en train
d'avoir un patrimoine en péril car il
n'y a pas si longtemps les portes de
l'éclusé s'ouvrait encore pour aller du
canal à la loire parler d'histoire
aujourd'hui toutes les péniches utilise
le pont-canal au dessus de la loire à
briare mais c'est une autre histoire